[Music]
Hey
looking good what is the best the
world-famous Marwin marx art
installation so that's a guy yeah it's
right out there some Nazi thugs jumped
him it's a miracle he survived I was a
hell of a good artist and now I could
barely write my name so my dogs have to
tell the story
after service members own
I just moved in across the street love
all the details who are they they're
Nazis torturing Oggy why because he's
different
the women of Marwan protect me you are
safe but toast just for you there are
the dogs people you know yeah everyone
has a place here in Marwan
I just moved in across the street so are
you gonna go to the sentencing no
suffering human being I want these guys
to get more than just a slap on the
wrist it's important that you're there
to look your assailant straight in the
eye I'm not really sure how to do this
are you gonna man up and put an end to
this crap what are you talking about
we're one in the same pal if I can be a
hero so can you maybe the dolls should
stay in the car
I never go anywhere without my back
nerds like you gotta embrace their king
it's the only way Marc's gonna heal I
can't repent okay bottoms up girls
[Applause]
but I heard you yelling for more gumbo
no no gumbo is a rocket fuel
I have my art and I have my friends I
have hope I'll be okay
hell yeah that's kind of violent but at
least the Nazis are dead
[Music]